[Musique]
hier soir à 20 heures le président de la
république emmanuel macron a fait son
allocution très attendue au sujet des
mesures sanitaires autour de la crise du
coc vide les établissements recevant du
public notamment les bars et restaurants
seront fermés des mesures qui sans
grande surprise ont impliqué un
confinement nationale voilà plusieurs
jours que la rumeur se faisait présente
et que de nombreux médias misez sur
cette annonce
sauf que jusqu alors personne ne savait
si ce confinement allait être totale ou
non et s'il allait impliquer la
fermeture définitive des commerces dits
non essentiels une fermeture annoncée
des restaurants qui inquiète au plus
haut point
ce n'est pas possible c'est inadmissible
c'est inadmissible après le premier
confinement déjà les difficultés
financières des restaurateurs s'étaient
multipliées aujourd'hui après le
couvre-feu et avec l' annonce de ce
nouveau confinement les professionnels
du secteur sont au bord du gouffre un
état d'esprit que confirme le cuisinier
philippe etchebest cette nouvelle
fermeture a posé un coup de grâce et une
mise à mort vu la situation financière
actuelle des professionnels du secteur
une question se pose fallait-il fermer
les restaurants fallait qu'il fermait
les restaurants philippe etchebest
nous on parlera dans un instant je
voulais d'abord avoir votre avis et on
aura voilà le sentiment de philippins
dans quelques minutes
s'il vous plaît vous ou non vous avez
vos petites banques à mouy dont
jean-marie gbot vainqueur mais j'ai dit
non non non ce qu'il fallait pas fermer
c'est ça sert pas à grand chose puisque
de toute façon les gens ont besoin de
vivre de boire un coup de rigoler avec
des potes
nous on l'a fait à la maison le passé
une soirée formidable
on était six sais pas si on a le droit
d'être 6 à la maison pour boire l'apéro
et puyrigaud les toits mais il s'attaque
un truc énorme parce que c'est la mise à
mort là là c'est pas on continue pas à
danser c'est la mise à mort des
restaurants et des bars c'est à dire que
bientôt il y aura plus de morts pendus
tu parles à la corde ou par le fusil de
chasse que par le cos vide c'est qu'elle
est à dire que mentalement ça va être
très compliqué pour toutes ces personnes
il y en a plein qui est envoyé plein de
mai soit plein de messages de gens qui
disent c'est vrai que ces voiles à ccc
terminé pour moi ces 20 années de
travail qui sont bons poussière vous
prenez ma ville vous dit qu'il fallait
pas les fermer
ah ben non c'est pas parce que j'avais
eu un panel sésame mais voilà c'était
surtout
parmi les temps qui courent on l'a ou
non seulement te confie de même
plusieurs il s'est passé des choses en
dehors de tous qui sommes des affreux et
quelques tirs pour pour tout est évadé
tu n'as plus rien et moi je suis venu
par le trait une de marseille ce matin
fallait voir dans la garde dans le train
on n'est qu'à j'ai pris le métro pour
aller à la gare et voir le monde de kala
le métro voilà j'ai pas voulu prendre
des photos parce qu'après on hurle
niveau est venu pour vite les autres
c'est inadmissible comme ferment les
retraités les tgv maintenant le droit de
sentein s'éclate pour fermer les bars
avec sa femme au restaurant au théâtre
où tout le monde est tourné dans le même
sens en alors adressé cinq heures dans
le tgv à 600 personnes et on n'a pas le
droit de rentrer une heure et demie d'un
théâtre pour regarder un truc pour se
distraire ses côtés jean éphémère tous
les commerces qui tourne autour des
restaurants notamment les taxis l'étape
comme l écart qui même les touristes
d'arrimage et de la direction mais voilà
il est inadmissible jean-michel vernis
mais vide
évidemment c'est un drame mais il faut
les fermer tous les spécialistes disent
que des courbes si on ne fait rien si on
n'apporte pas un coup d'arrêt dans
quelques quinzaine quelques semaines il
y aura des centaines de milliers de
morts il faut arrêter tout dans le train
évidemment on est obligé de se déplacer
pour le travail et dans le train on peut
garder le masque dans reste en tête bien
où j'ai retiré ton masque en partie bon
tout ça a duré deux restants pour manger
et c'est pas et sans cela resté un tro t
1 regarde sur masque jeunesse a pris moi
demain ce que c'était formidable
bah oui les balades thomas seront
interdits du restaurant bêche louvain et
nous dire de restaurer le pont pourrait
peut-être ouvrir des
et théâtre je trouve qu'ils ont pris ces
voix là c'est le bouc émissaire de les
restaurants parce que ça fait très mal
parce que c'est pas dans les restaurants
même on aurait pu adapter on aurait pu
dire pour moi par exemple the formula
21h elle me plaisait bien ça plaisait
pas des gens mais au moins le restant
ils bossaient le midi il faisait un
chiffre d'affaires loire lundi soir il
faisait un peu il y avait les gens de
kiaka parce qu'on dit aux gens d'aller
travailler dans les bureaux et les gens
qui m'ont trahi dans les bureaux qui
pouvaient sortir ne me dis allez manger
au restaurant chez moi ça fait 28 ans
que j'ai vu les restes ans j'ai fait que
ça de toute ma vie livrer les restants
j'ai jamais connu les restaurants depuis
ces dernières années depuis le
confinement j'ai jamais connu des
restaurants aussi propre aussi propre
bien-être et on n'a jamais désinfecter
des tables avant quand on a les
restaurants les tables sont désinfectés
il ya du gel ya les espaces alors il
faut ils ont peut-être pas fait là ils
ont fait la demande
ils sont trompés entre les péniches les
soirées où tu bois des mojitos tu
t'embrasse où tout le monde est un peu
éméché avec un restaurant il ya des ça
va être un drame alors c'est sa demande
et des baskets avec nous bonsoir bonsoir
philippe merci d'être là philippe
vraiment merci et et on comprend
vraiment votre désarroi et j'ai vu plein
de gens moi aujourd'hui plein de potes
quand on débarque dans des restaurants
qui est que j'ai eues en pleurs au
téléphone qui m'ont dit cyril mois ces
dix années 20-30 ans travail qui part en
poussière je sais que je me relèverai
plus c'est l'histoire d'une vie pour
beaucoup de gens beaucoup de familles ça
c'est terrible
imaginez vous la tous autour de du
plateau là vous êtes tous des bons
vivants imaginer qu'un jour vous
puissiez plus jamais mangé au restaurant
vont aller boire un coup dans un bar
qu'est ce que vous feriez métro boulot
dodo c'est ce qui va se passer on vrai
et le lien social il va est rompu et ça
va être terrible
alors on peut pas après rivaliser avec
la santé parce qu'elle est important que
la santé j'entends mais comment
aujourd'hui en 2020 qu on à avoir à
choisir entre la santé et l'économie
ça je ne le comprends pas ensuite pour
rebondir sur ce cas des monsieur
guillard
oui dans les tgv pour qu'on ait six ans
mais je veux rajouter un truc pourquoi
dans les trains on est puissant et qu'en
plus on peut manger on est train c'est
arrivé at il expliqué quand même nom
mais la raison ça philippe ça c'est ça
c'est une vraie question mine de rien
parce que même si on peut plus manger au
bar on peut manger
la loi la grosse rigolade c'est qu'à
l'hôtel tu peux faire le tu peux manger
à l'hôtel mai à 9h voitures entrent dans
ta chambre
non mais c'est le ba tu veux ip tube est
qu'elle quelles seraient vos solutions
ce que vous avez ici je sais que vous
avez eu un moment où vous voyez vous en
avait parlé avec edouard philippe à
l'époque avec l'ancien premier ministre
quelles sont les solutions pour les
restaurateurs parce que là on voit il
n'y a pas de solution pour eux ils vont
être obligés de fermer si tu penses que
ça va être pour un mois un mois et demi
encore au moins voire même je pense un
peu plus c'est ça va être une
catastrophe
les solutions elles sont question les
solutions et il ya eu des aides qui ont
été donnés un moment donné pendant
premier confinement des êtres qui n'ont
pas suffi imaginé au départ c'était 1500
euros pour certains restaurateurs
attention pas tous d'accord avec 1500
euros quand vous avez trois mille 4000
euros de loyer quand vous avez quatre
mille 4000 euros de de frais fixes à
payer et que vous ne vous versez même
pas de salaire au juste m'expliquer
comment on fait qu'ils supporteraient
aujourd'hui de ne pas être payés pendant
plus de sept mois pendant plus de sept
mois et c'est une réalité
est ce que est ce qu'un fonctionnaire
l'accepta est ce qu'un médecin accepte
presque un professeur personnes
accepterait ça et pourtant dans notre
métier ça arrive
il ya des gens aujourd'hui qui ne se
verse plus de salaire depuis sept mois
alors aujourd'hui ce qui se passe c'est
une mise à mort de notre profession
d'une grande partie de la profession
il ya plusieurs mois j'ai annoncé deux
cent cinquante mille pertes d'emplois
30% de file on y va et droit mais met
carrément on va droit dans le mur et je
pense c'est une estimation optimiste que
j'ai et elle était elle a été révélée
par l'insee sur les courts le premier
sim semestre il y avait 140 4000 chômage
supplémentaire la sodexo qui est une
grosse boîte après 2000 suppressions
d'emplois là donc vous vous rendez
compte
ça concerne tous les petits et les gros
mais un discours aujourd'hui il y avait
beaucoup de petits les tpe elles sont et
non rien à 160 milles en france c'est
quand même grave à ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui ce sont des familles qui
vont être détruites et caen et caen et
quand le gouvernement et plusieurs
scientifiques disent que c'est
obligatoire parce qu'aujourd'hui le
restaurant les barques c'est trop
dangereux et c'est pour pour le virus on
est obligé pour arrêter
la propagation du virus ou leur vous
leur répondez quoi si je peux me
permettre une chose moi je suis pas
scientifique je ne suis pas médecin
d'accord j'ai lu un rapport de l'aïe est
d'accord at il dit les clusters la
grosse partie des classes à la vienne
des universités des collèges du foyer
des foyers privés aussi parce que qu'est
ce qui va empêcher les gens aujourd'hui
de se réunir chez eux sans aucune
pression sans aucun chef de barrières
non sécurisé ont quand même les clients
notre lente et les données personnelles
à des coupes arrière sont responsables
non on n'est plus sûr de plusieurs
restaurants vides chez soi vous si vous
aviez un dernier mot à dire sur soir à
noter les régulateurs des messages à
faire passer tout ça avec moi philippe
prix fixe et internet
si je vous le dis avait un dernier
message à faire passer il va falloir une
façon on n'a pas le choix aujourd'hui on
voit bien qu'on a pas le choix on chibi
les choses maintenant ce que j'ai envie
de dire c'est pas aux téléspectateurs ce
gouvernement est à nos syndicats de se
battre de se battre pour me définir de
ne faire qu'une seule voix et surtout
après ses décisions qu'il faut assumer
mais c'est d'aider la profession mais de
l'aider pour de vrai exactement
merci en tout cas philippe gilbert je
sais qu'ils se battent tous les jours
pour tous les restaurateurs des fibres
vraiment je vais vous dire chapeau pour
ce que vous faites et continuez à vous
battre et vraiment je sais comme vous
devez avoir plein de potes aussi qui qui
sont vraiment dans une situation
inextricable et vos si ça doit vous
miner tous les jours comme nous ici
et bravo à vous de vous battre et
d'essayer de faire passer merci philippe
d'avoir été avec nous merci beaucoup tu
dis merci et continuez